non je maison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir conte de blanche
maison
merci d'être avec nous alors tout
d'abord la première réaction des manuels
macro et angela merkel à l'issue de ce
conseil des ministres franco allemand
conserve ce dont on vient de parler à
l'instant cette affaire d'espionnage
l'europe se devait de réagir vite
oui bien sûr parce que on le dit souvent
tout le monde écoute tout le monde et
les grands pays
parfois aidées par des pipes le petit
écoute un petit peu tout le monde
mais avec les moyens techniques dont ils
disposent et les responsables politiques
des différents états des responsables
diplomatiques en principe dispose de
moyens de communications cryptées et
avec les progrès techniques actuelles
certains codes sont impossibles à casser
cela dit à partir du moment où quelqu'un
affichent publiquement qu'il a coopéré
pour écouter un dirigeant évidemment ils
étaient cent il est évidemment
nécessaire de protester c'est
inacceptable dans accepté le principe
mais les écoutes sont absolument
généralisé de la part de beaucoup de
pays
à telle enseigne que la difficulté est
souvent de les archiver de les conserver
et de savoir ce que l'on en fait donc là
on a un problème qui est que la
révélation a été faite sur la place
publique et que par conséquent bien
entendu monsieur macro et madame merkel
sont dans l'obligation de réagir et de
demander des explications aux états unis
d'amérique et au danemark
la chancelière dont qui présidait pour
la dernière fois son conseil des
ministres franco-allemand avec emmanuel
macron ce conseil justement est ce que
c'est une rencontre purement formelle ou
ou la véritable assurance d'une
coopération suivi on pourrait croire que
c'est formel puisque ces rencontres ont
un rythme annuel depuis que le président
chirac et le chancelier schröder les
avait créé en 2003 et
effectivement surtout en période de
pandémie où l'on voit les deux équipes
nationales réuni chacune dans leur
capital
mais en réalité ce n'est pas la réalité
ça ne correspond pas à ce qui se passe
en réalité puisque comme vous l'avez dit
chaque binôme ministériel doit faire le
point sur les progrès qui ont été
accomplis par rapport à la réunion
précédente et par conséquent ça veut
dire que chaque ministre demande à son
administration de faire le point ça veut
dire qu'en amour il ya eu des rencontres
bilatérales au niveau des fonctionnaires
au niveau des ministres et que du côté
allemand comme du côté français les
administrations sont mobilisés et en
effet la coopération franco allemande
dans tous les domaines et est très
importante et souvent portent sur des
sujets assez technique
il y avait aujourd'hui une bonne
douzaine de ministres de chaque côté on
le voyait lors de la conférence de
presse tout à l'heure les ministres les
plus importants étaient là tels bilan
peut-on faire de cette relation durant
quatre ans entre la chancelière et le
président français vient je crois
d'abord que la chancelière et le
président français ont appris à faire
confiance
tout simplement parce que ils savent
aussi que la la la coopération entre la
france et l'allemagne est absolument
essentiel qu'elle est dans l'intérêt de
chacun des deux pays
alors le grand succès naturellement de
cette coopération a été le plan de
relance européenne qui a été décidé en
mai de l'année dernière avec un montant
de 750 milliards d'euros qui ensuite a
été reformulée par la commission
européenne et avec beaucoup de
difficulté d'ailleurs adoptée par les
autres états membres puis avalisé plus
récemment par le parlement européen un
an finalement ça n'est pas beaucoup pour
mettre en oeuvre une novation de cette
importance puisque ça veut dire que dès
le mois de juin
la commission européenne va pouvoir
emprunter sur les marchés mondiaux
une grande première elle va pouvoir
utiliser sa capacité d'emprunt qui est
considérable et qui jusqu'à présent
était gelée elle n'avait pas le droit de
l'utiliser
et pour prêter ou donner des fonds aux
états membres correspondant aux plans
qui ont été présentés par les états mans
qui ont été discutées et avalisés
ensuite à bruxelles
donc ça c'est un succès franco allemand
et il y a deux ans une telle hypothèse
était parfaitement inimaginable on peut
penser qu emmanuel macron avec ses
arguments financiers a convaincu la
chancelière qui elle est une
scientifique et qui comprend les
arguments techniques
elle a très rapidement vu qu'il fallait
relancer l'économie européenne
il fallait une forme de solidarité est
une forme de communautarisation de cette
nouvelle dette c'est-à-dire de l'emprunt
qui allait être fait sur le marché sur
le marché international on voit donc
aussi qu' il ya une culture commune qui
se développent et par exemple lorsque le
président macron parle d'identité
stratégiques européennes dans le domaine
international
cette expression ne plaît pas beaucoup
aux allemands parce qu'ils ont peur que
ce soit dirigée contre le lien
transatlantique
mais finalement on s'aperçoit que tout
le monde peut être l'accord autour du
titre de souveraineté européenne et par
conséquent là encore on peut ménager les
susceptibilités en voyant quels sont les
points qui irrite le partenaire et il ya
là donc une longue pratique que le
président macron et la chancelière ont
repris la chancelière le fait depuis
longtemps elle l'a fait avec plusieurs
pays dont la république française et le
président macron a bien utilisés je
pense cet instrument puisqu'il ya eu ce
succès marquant l'année dernière alors
évidemment maintenant il faut préparer
la suite merci on suivra ça évidemment
merci que l'autre blanchemaison expert
en relations internationales